je te connais pas toi mais où es tu me
connais alors lio est ce que tu es prête
on va faire une interview fin du monde
c'est encore une idée à 10 ans 20 ans
bien alors c'est la fin du monde
tu peux sauver un livre lequel tu sauf
les belles endormies de kawabata parce
que c'est un livre érotique entre des
toutes jeunes filles est un très vieux
monsieur qu'il regarde dormir dans un
bordel japonais et c'est vraiment tendre
et c'est vraiment lent est bon et doux
et il ya la jeunesse et la vieillesse
ensemble et comme en attendant toujours
à séparer les deux je trouve ça un
niveau magnifique et si tu devais
choisir un héros local
corto maltese rock corto maltese oui
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
jamais laissé abattre
quand il a vu qu'il n'avait pas de ligne
de chance dans sa main ben ça qui s'en
est fait une au rasoir
je trouve qu'il faut toujours être au
rasoir dans la vie et si tu devais
emporté un journal aucun journal aucun
aucun aucun je trouve qu'il faudrait
tout recommencer à zéro parce que c'est
pas de l'info c'est de la désinformation
quelle voiture tu choisirais une
thunderbird bleu ciel comme y avait dans
american graffiti l'a préféré à une
émission de télé liot je garde pas
d'émissions télé je pense que je
regarderai même pas la télé un couture
et j'ai dit entre azdine et la croix je
peux pas prendre les deux tu peux oui
les deux un monument je sais pas
peut-être peut-être la tour eiffel parce
qu'elle pointe haut vers le ciel et en
même temps elle à quatre pattes bien
carré par terre et puis quelle est belle
quand elle éclaire et ça fait comme de
la dentelle
où est la tour eiffel et une fleur lio
un coquelicot
tu sais pourquoi parce que les
coquelicots d'abord on peut pas les
cueillir
ça se flétrit tout de suite donc c'est
vraiment une fleur accrochée à la vie
que les pas prétentieuse et pourtant il
est rouge sang en plus elles poussent le
long des chemins de fer et les sauvages
c'est une rebelle 5 fleur rebelle et
fragile chelem cette fleur chante tout
le clic on est un gentil coquelicot
messieurs et un astre le soleil le
soleil parce que c'est la chaleur parce
que c'est la vie parce que sans soleil a
pas de vie parce que c'est rayonnant et
parce que c'est l'amour et moi je crois
qu'on sache quoi quand l'amour et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus